misleading
welcome
nailed it nailed it
this is rocket league i am joined with
chris waters mary kish hi rob hey guys
there is some new dlc out for the
spectacular game
lord knows there is and it is beautiful
it is real hot so many hot looks so many
hot looks and it's also four freaking
dollars so it's a must buy in my opinion
we're watching chris play with the new
car oh you won what
no it said winner orange i was blue oh i
i started that match to test the live
stream capabilities right and now i'm
going to join you guys now we know what
it looks like cool so let's win some
games but first
the new stuff you get when you get the
dlc all right you got it now if we look
over to my screen we have a garage here
uh two new cars
one
dominus
which is my fave of the two and then
down down here which is what chris was
rocking
the takuma takumi
it's a beaut it's a beaut it's got style
it's got style or miles
move on here so each car
also gets new
iterations of these standard
decals well they're not all standard
because you've got scorpions in there
ain't no scorpions on so exactly no
other situations so this this is a
unique pertaining to the dominus
scorpion
and also you got tats down here which is
also or is it
this is also pretty unique
no but these basic ones are all
different now or
kind of redesigned for each one of these
here the takumi actually has crazy
enough like a bunch of unique ones oh
yeah it's got a cat with a halo
all right yeah all right into the garage
for me okay
it's you should cat halo it you
you also get
new paint jobs
look in here you get curd brush
yeah look at that brushed metal mama
metallic pearl the pearl and the
pearlescent do this neat thing where
like from different angles it kind of
blends your secondary color with your
primary color you can see there uh the
or that color fade yeah it's pretty
slick it's pretty slick and then you got
the classic wood i feel like the wood
looks best with an accent
because
accent colors here
you can get kind of like the brownish
yeah make it look like some actual wood
paneling actually on the outside of a
car which is totally a real thing that
used to happen right moving on we have
some hot tires here
you got didn't used to be able to punch
people when you saw cars that had that
wood paneling
no was that that was for a volkswagen
bug and that was just a punchbox
there's another one for the wood
paneling what are those called
from a real punchy area of the country
never heard of that one what we used to
always find reasons to punch our friends
i'm not alone moving on from the
punching
here we have i cannot read because it's
far away cristiano
which is a soccer ball hub but
you're not getting that you're going
with the spinners
that's a good spinner voice isn't it i
feel like that's the i feel like if
spinners could vocalize that's what they
would say yeah it'd just be a constant
yelling like they'd be like
oh really that's not your best work kish
well let's get to some races okay no we
have two more things here
you get two more rocket trails this one
is awesome it's burnout and it makes a
sweet sound effect like
like when you're like approaching these
like layups it's exhilarating i've like
done a couple matches and just been gone
in 60 seconds style oh it's fantastic
and then you got probably the most
rocket league
trail is nitrous
and
sets it on fire it almost looks like
it's a ticking time bomb which one are
you doing so i'm going with burnout all
right i'll do nitrous so we can see both
of them in action i also have nitrous
great plan everybody wins just the basic
update also comes with new hats and such
but uh nothing
pertaining to the dlc but that's all she
wrote
let's fire it up here huh yeah let's do
it get us into a match here nope but not
to me too we don't want to play a season
because no one plays season unless they
want some chivos boring tropheos
four what what what yep ranked yeah i'm
gonna play some ranked do it i think so
do it doug
uh i put on a dumb little snowman on my
thing because you guys had dumb little
things on youtube so
normally i kind of like to play without
it a lot of the time sure i like the
cleaner look but i figured for the sake
of streaming
it'd be fun why not why not i see you
got the spinners there do we all
spinners nope kish's got mary's actually
my favorite yeah those are actually my
favorite those are really good i just
think they're hot they are you are you
nailed it
you nailed it that is accurate i made it
i made a personal call
uh there's also there was a free patch
to update uh some stuff in the game
putting in like 3v3 ranked for example
all right we should play i'm going for
it
oh
yeah 3v theory uh ranked you get the
spectator mode which is fanduel you
taste nice ski rob nice d thank you
spectator mode which yeah hopefully
we'll be able to spectate some sweet uh
some sweet rocket leagues oh god my
flips
yeah there we go there we go no dlc
will make you better at this game but
the spectator stuff is free as is the
new map which hopefully we will get to
see oh it's right there there it is
kish punching at home for the first goal
of the match
to team game spot
sorry ziggler e nuts
ziggle nuts
we're playing against zvr official
calgary creeper and ziggle nuts what's
up y'all it's ziggle nuts
roberto
you also get new controller okay did you
get
stop that's why that early
d is so important sorry oh no it's open
oh my bad that's gonna go
sorry i shouldn't get in there so when
you're playing with three people you
want to try to get this rotation going
right where someone's already back but
like rob pushes up there i should have
dropped back because i was off the play
right and then we would have had someone
if you want to leave
the
the coveted spot all right i'm going in
all right i'm back
then just say so so that we can have
someone else
you know
be there oh my god i need help
oh is that going in it could it could go
it is oh
i almost actually deflected that high i
think it was not a great idea for me to
follow that i mean following a shot like
this is a good idea case it like comes
short but like
it's very possible i could have hit it
into the cross
cross bar and it goes
for the same thing with like defending
like sometimes you just don't
i think he just yells at me oh no oh
what
yeah
you doing i was reading i think that
person told me to eat a dick
yeah
you don't need to read rude things
you need to goaltend sorry i was reading
no you had that
you could have gotten it all right
uh homosexuals like bigoted slurs so
obviously we're gonna have to destroy
i'm pretty excited about that yeah now
we got ourselves a match
these people are scum
well specifically one of them we've
determined who the who the [ __ ] is
in this match yeah not not all of them
are
scum
necessarily just because they are
associating with scum here we go
but if you're taking time to like type
in hate speech nice
using the keypad maybe you should like
reevaluate your life situation right
heck i got behind me
yep yeah yeah
[ __ ] i centered it
oh
with the goal i'd save
nice work
all right they're coming in for a strong
center
just let it go by no oh i got it
they were there
all right
so i sorry i should have been more
aggressive on the wing there if we have
someone in goal
like
waiting too much on defense can be
perilous
you know what i'll defend here you know
what's funny is we were playing last
night and
you're beginning to see some unique
teams like the first time it was this
team and they were all trucks all with
[ __ ] technology
oh
i got your back boy damn i'm on the wall
he's there
all right
i didn't have her back that time i could
only have that back and then i tried to
feel like it all started going downhill
after i didn't
help
listen this is just the ebb and flow of
a rocket league match
it was
it was worse the smack talk began
don't let it don't let it rattle you
just play your game you know haha i'm
back i'm back
good
i missed it again it's a big old whiff
fest here in the center field
um oh i missed it oh we need it we need
you on that rob i got it that's nice
mary
way to clear that they're coming in all
right i'm going up
mmm
center denied
oh i'm on it
nice
nope
nope i went past it oh sorry
uh
is an angry man
i'm back here
oh i shot it i shot it no
i would probably be mad too if my name
was ziggle nuts
sorry
guys
mr ziggle nuts he made it like a day
later he's like damn it
i tried to cross it
but
oh hi oh we're not spamming the chat
here no problem no problem you got to
get in their heads no problem
oh that's a fly
it's hot it's weird that one's all up
all right i need to activate some
spinner mojo here
nice it doesn't set
nice
oh
nice oh what's it what's up what's up
we going we're going central you got a
center coming yep i do okay i do i do
they're going to be oh
i'm going around
higher
nice
back over here oh
nope that was a bouncer
ah
nice that worked out yeah buddy
throw that car that was into the way of
the shot that was 100 percent accident
oh [ __ ] i missed it
oh that's the two [ __ ] i tried to
the boost i got it oh the boost misses
are the worst because you you go way
past yeah oh no it's okay
it's not okay it is very not okay you
guys made it okay
nice save getting our d game together
here i like it
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i got it
nice yeah yeah yeah yeah
here we go
oh that's all right
oh no no i was off oh i'm not watching
that wow they knocked it out themselves
they must not really want this
i'm way off you got that rob yeah kind
of
i think this is gonna go down as a loss
guys yeah that's right it's a warm-up
match as a team
i just don't know this car that well you
know you gotta when you have new wheels
you gotta
you gotta get used to them
well you gotta break it in so we have to
access the main menu this is another
thing that i really wish they would
patch is just a way to re-cue for a
ranked match
once you
are done with the ranked match as it is
now you have to back out to
the menu
and then re-enter i wonder if that's
because it automatically puts you into
the next match and they don't want you
doing that in ranked they want you to
take it seriously and actively you know
be in the zone for each individual game
i mean it's still pretty tedious when
one has any other ranked
multiplayer game done that before they
could give you the option to
just like next like queue for next match
and then if it times out they kick you
back to the menu
right
also uh with recent patch and update i
don't i'm not hearing any peeps coming
from your dual shock
here we go
i turned mine down because it was
getting a little ridiculous actually
that's a strong start nice
actually uh daniel dwyer told me to turn
mine down because it was pretty loud
in the garage it's like chick chick
chick chick no this is a different group
that's a bummer
you want a rematch i wanted to remax
well we could if we play not ranked you
can vote to rematch the only parallel of
not ranked is like there's no penalty
for people quitting and so
you get the quitters you get pretty good
but then you just end up playing against
a bot so it's not that bad bots are
okay i'm gonna shoot this all right
oh
got blocked
waited a little longer for that one how
are we doing here destroy this guy oh
boom baby
i took my chance
all right
oh
they got you've got a strong goalkeeper
there yeah well as soldier
he's gonna be to be on it
centered
i actually didn't think i needed it
the dominus
so now this is a three on two
oh did someone leave i didn't know
because it doesn't uh it doesn't
repopulate well that's just cruel that's
unlucky
but if they think we're going easy on
them
coming oh yeah
nice save man
uh it was uh roberto i i named it hey
rob nice save thanks chris
let's keep pushing huh
let's
do it
oh oh that's a set that's a set uh
because we're super hyped oh that's
another one
insurance on my part no problem get in
there
oh that was a good shot off the post
right the
musical listen if you're not getting
impassioned by playing rocket league
what are you doing all right
who's back i'm on that d
that's what i like to hear
chubby killer coming in for the center
oh that's a high one that's a high
ingredient oh that was dope but i went
for it
i'm gonna clear that i'm just gonna i'm
going all right
hit it
it's gonna wrap its way around
it's gonna work its way out
i love how rob sounds like a bird of
prey whenever he goes
that's oh
oh i missed i got too excited oh good
job
i hope there's
someone left in the chat
give me that hat trick yeah
lopsided hat trick i don't care
it's lopsided all right i'm back i'm in
i didn't mean to say omg sorry guys
yeah well so if you hit the other car
they go really fast i find that if i
just give you a little tap taparoo
you are really likely to get there first
i like that i know it's a good system
you know i've done a couple times is uh
just demolished another dude in that
first it's actually so fun it's coming
not even not even through all oh yeah
it's i just started
you know what the hell man
sorry rob it's all right it's all right
uh my aerial vector was
not on the wall
yeah when you're up for zero
yay playing against
two players
now we're having some fun yeah there we
see the burnout and nitrous
boost situations
you know i really like games where it's
3v2 it's just a better experience
i feel like these guys might be wanting
to say something in the chat they're not
really moving
it might this might be the mark of
typing something out oh oh downtown
philly
has just uh stepped away
oh she's out yeah so if you like one of
the i haven't actually experimented with
this myself three did they eventually
let it no if so someone leaves your team
the first person to quit gets a 15 gets
a penalty to when they can re-queue for
matchmaking but if somebody on your team
leaves before you you can leave whenever
you want then you can leave without
penalty so chubby killer should really
just what happens when there's no one
left do we actually play win by forfeit
we don't finish the game is over
you guys let's play backwards
what was that let's play backwards okay
let's play okay
sure this seems
okay you'll learn valuable skills
all right let's do it here we go
oh if i score i'm going to feel so good
about myself that's fair
i don't know is this center is this that
much more cruel i guess yeah oh crap
get there
no i missed it
got it has it i'm dribbling
this is dribbling rebels
got them dribbles
oh he hit me
um yes
you can't really destroy people all
right make it center
hey we can't use dish that's you
oh
it's really hard it is really hard oh
ah okay i'm on my butt
here it's coming centered oh
i'm coming oh no i've got it i hit it
way too far
damn it
oh no he's taking it he's taking it home
no he's not oh i missed him
the gentle bumps i'm in the goal
are you doing the like i'm flipping
around in the goal yeah i'm not sure how
to get out of the goal situation oh no
what did i do
what do i do what's the opposite of a
center oh my god
why
i'm not there
i think that they missed that yes
all right that was a good match good job
only kind of running up the score
let's give him a gg
thanks for hanging in there buddy
kudos to you hell of a guy great job you
know i bet i bet he's in all around
really should we play uh just not ranked
we should buy him lunch
that way we could possibly rematch yeah
yeah that's standard that's smart
let's do that everybody feeling good
about their car designs here i'm pretty
content they are pretty sick i also like
that you can now see your whole team's
cars in this menu screen right that's a
nice little patch update
uh we have yet to play on this stream
the new map but it takes place in like
this kind of
big open coliseum looking place yeah i
said it looked like dr seuss's coliseum
dr seuss's collection it's like really
colorful and
bright vibrant genteel all right we're
playing forwards there's a lot of people
saying playing for reminds them of like
mario kart it's just got those really
bright colors
yeah and it's also doesn't have the like
very clear like walls and ceiling bit
right it's just kind of like a low
railing no it's not gonna go it had so
much english on it but i really
respected it
oh
wow that's right
okay
we're playing a competitive game now
not like the last one so you know that
decision
okay okay okay once you go backwards you
don't go back what bird
huh
here we go oh yeah that was a whiff
by the other team you guys are perfect
in every way
oh i blew it regardless damn it
damn it
coming back in
kind of i'm here
oh what who did that i did
it was the kiss for the best it worked
out okay
oh we got some aerial shenanigans
centering
nope
oh coming back in front again
you can hear the pants
coming from so far away
oh it's right there
oh did you do the sideways rocket you
made that shot way more complicated than
it needed to be but it looked cool i got
it i'm always challenging myself
every day
i think
what could i do
how could i make everything more
difficult like who's awesome who's our
goalie i'm back i'm back
well thanks i guess i'm not you don't
want me to be back you're fine
no way we need you
damn it
mixed messages i don't understand
that was a nice shot by shaveman
shaven my favorite
shaveman you know it
so many good names
shaveman 86.
turning 30 next year shaveman what are
you doing with your life wax on wax off
i'm back
just in case
you never know
rob i'm going to need me you know just
give me a heads up when you're coming in
for the gotta fly chris oh crap oh no i
went for it i have no i hit him out of
the way nice jock him that was cool
okay
i'll go out for it i'll be back
i'll support you
like emotionally yes
say good job or something you can't just
say i'll support you well i thought that
was the support
support
oh [ __ ] the bicycle shop
come here
come here you giant ball i want it
oh he wants it he's gonna have it oh
that's it i got a piece oh
sorry good angle
animal noises i'm going back
i like it
oh damn it that was a shot a ricochet
weirdo shot
couldn't have planned it
but it went wide
and now orange team is back
fighting for possession at midfield
there's been a lot of whips here today
coming into the air it's it's going to
be
a situation ah
you know what i have my
my like
my one problem
keep rolling i do like a double tap roll
every time just too excited it is it's a
it's a pure excitement oh oh [ __ ] get it
out
with the roll save up top
i can't high five you right now but i
totally would but i support you
good pursuit bad angle they were all
over you all right let me set it
what is that kiss you on that uh it was
ripped from my from my hands
it's coming back in the middle oh it's
gonna get ripped
i'll stop that
i will arrest your balls moment
oh i should have called you off
oh get it
i'm on it come and get me get it i know
that's what the ball is saying to you
uh-oh
no it's cool
oh i think i got a piece of it how do
you guys feel like these new decals
have impacts nice
nice save i know it's fine it's fine i
think the cat decal makes me feel a bit
feistier
oh oh oh oh oh oh no i missed it chris
sorry i was coming in i should have
called call me yup totally totally my
bad i called you off
all right it's coming
nope it's not
i could only delay it slightly
that's going wide oh
sorry i got nervous all right that's all
right
i guess everything worked out okay
all right we got 20 seconds left
let's not go into overtime you guys
okay i don't like it like that attitude
there it is there it is for you guys
slide slide finish what i started my
angle was wrong i should have flipped i
can do one more
we can do one more
what are you doing
yeah double g now it's just not a genie
situation okay we need a strong d i
think i'm gonna be lurking i'm gonna be
working back i'll be lurking all right
oh that guy's okay are you gonna make a
play on this i will clear this
oh
now they've come back
i'm going to center
oh i missed it
i know what centers look like
and you sir did no center you are a liar
oh no
rob are you good yep
oh man with that aerial tap tap
beautiful i'll be back in my goal
beautiful path
through the air
no no no no no no
yeah who did that
no i meant was it going in before i
touched it
because i know it was it was going right
to me i was going to knock it out
miscommunication
of mental errors in overtime
gg shame that's all right let's go
rematch yeah let's vote rematch we're
gonna get this is why we did this this
is remember here we do it again
listen own goals are part of the process
here i made a call you guys
we call that a new house
when you shoot it
in your own thoughts
alex new house is known for
really just bringing bringing people
down bringing the own goals
let's to be fair he has also
distinguished himself in other ways by
being good at doing other stuff but
really
what really defines his presence on the
field is
the new house smash aka own goals and he
like eventually came to realize it
just
i
all right guys we need the w we need a
legit w right here right now
for team blue
you want to see a cool cinematic shot
when this thing comes off yeah
is it bad is that it no josh come to me
cut to meet you here we go ready yeah oh
you guys are
you guys aren't playing that was it why
didn't you get in
what happened i like the way your
question was formed didn't you get in uh
get it but i've been loading for a while
now
maybe you guys will win no you're going
to come in late why don't you uh like
because there's no way because there's
still a um an ai here is merlin ai
lolofap joined the match hooray brand
great everyone is very excited
no you know you're out you're officially
out should we exit and get marian yes
all right
especially now that they've scored
see ya see ya
mary you probably might have to quit
your game and or something the whole
game maybe you guys might oh just do it
i'm gonna need a uh
find your words cable to charge my
controller
joshua
i need some tech
assistance
oh
well my controller is out of battery i
know that was a thing you could be known
for
that the kish
i don't know
is it
all right rob show us some more show us
some more uh
i don't know car designs or something
okay
so i so yeah they redid
a lot of um the decals original ones so
for instance let's take a look here did
they
yeah they did i think i think they're
pretty damn hot go to a decal i'm in so
like look at like skulls right here like
that's like is that new i think that's
new do you remember schools being like
that i don't know i can't tell you
josh says he thinks that skull's on the
van
they do that the decals vary from
from van de van exactly
i'm in let's do it let's see oh she's in
yeah enough of this garbage all right
let's switch it up to the crazy eight oh
i do not want oh i do not want this van
what am i doing
rob will you just
head in the game taxi man okay yeah
gotta get your racing stripes get your
eagle wings come on
there you go thanks you're a bird of
prey ready to strike
now all we have to do is win
we will win
we're gonna do it i gotta guys i got a
good feeling about this what is the plan
here
coach kish
yeah coach well
what do you got
i think that we need to call it a little
bit more okay that's that's good that's
all voice communication i think i got it
respect each other
and
we're all good here do you feel
disrespected no
that feels good it's just good to remind
i just wanted to let you guys know
culture how much
yeah
all right i'm defending here
i'm gonna try to center all right go for
it
did not get a piece of it
i think i should have tried my eyesight
isn't nearly as good at nighttime i
don't like these nighttime games
i just cleared someone out of the goal i
think it was mary that's fine all right
i'm running it up
running it
kind of uh someone yeah so we've got a
bot in the match that was why there was
like a little bit of lag there oh yeah
there's that twisted metal bar that
means he's probably nice
just means he's played a lot rob no it
means um he like he had the game during
beta i think no you can unlock twisted
metal card by winning matches with like
basically every car have you unlocked it
yes oh wow
how'd you know that see i wish they i
wish they made things like that more
clear internet
says it it does
the you go to the like [ __ ] the blank
screen
yeah what a save
oh thank
there's a lot of whiffing
yeah kish time to clean it up
nice pass
great pass cause you're beautiful
beautiful
wow all right well let's not get too
tender now we still have a whole match
to play amen
no problem defending
oh we need you
we need you right i like that the
controller noise for like
saves into a play there off of your hit
mary
well
it hasn't paid dividends yet but i'm
optimistic that something good will come
of it well we're all connected so it's
possible that that set off a chain of
events that causes us to win
guys we're all connected
damn
who's in goal
i got the cross
so that's huge too right like if if two
people are quote defending and both go
for that
run there then it's just like then you
leave the goal open and then you're then
you're done
yeah sometimes like if you're if you're
back there and you can't really make a
play on the ball you just uh take it off
ball cam
oh totally just try to jock ball cam is
not always the best no you're cause it
changes your angle
yeah i've heard you're supposed to
switch but yeah if you turn off ball cam
you can get
more of a strafe going
get in there
nice nice
yep yep yep yep yep yep
you popped oh i should have taken out
the goalie see right there i should have
taken the goalie out back and then rob
hello just some incidents you know it's
funny though someone took me out as i
was like have that approach
nice
rob i'm gonna center do it please do it
it's a very gentle center oh i've
totally whipped it like a jackass oh
balls i left it's a goal because totally
whipped it it's all right no problem no
problem no problem thank you christopher
no problem
turk you did the what a save technique
which is
really a big f.u
so you know what is i agree that is
really rude but i can't see i'm a little
far away from tv
down and left man down left so that's
training for left and down is what a
save i'm trying to do no problem so it's
down left yeah i know you got to know
these things so if you
if you get the rhythm off we've
for instance if you
uh expire what do you call it uh chat
disabled
then you throw off your rhythm your
rhythm oh this rhythm if you're uh this
is good oh oh i got cards
i'm a little worried
oh
that was tight the only whiff that
counts it doesn't
wait never mind what nothing now you
have to good job i want to know more
everyone is doing okay
i want to know how this ends keep up the
good work team go team
all right here we go that could be a set
oh
no that's fine that's good
stolen
center oh nope nope that wall game is
tough i'm not a super awesome wall gamer
i gotta say nope that didn't work out
oh it's coming back i got it
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh it was ugly he blocked me god damn
it's all right it came up even watch
this block right here what a series of
butchers right
bam dink
what'd you just say
forget it so forget it something about
butts cars don't have butts i'm going
back too because i'm afraid
equivocation mary go go go i called it
damn oh dag this one's weird this is a
weird one
missed it
oh this is a weird one
that's a high one that's a weirdo
okay he's returning it
oh i jumped [ __ ] i zigged when i should
have gone
i'm not sure what that means
here we go this is the w we've been
searching for
mm-hmm
uh-huh
rob stark
oh
okay oh
nice
everyone all focus in ot they're hungry
get some clearance clarence
what's your vector victor
oh no i did not touch that
but see that's like the side line can
seem like oh no rob we need to say
oh
i think i don't score that a little bit
i blew it so
quick let's not watch this
option
where yeah i was going in we're getting
a lot of our own medicine here
no problem no problem rematch
one more time
this one for all the marbles
we're gambling marbles on this situation
by the way
rob how do you feel about that
performance let's get some post game
analysis
um it's one of those things where uh i
just kind of sucked
i'm back can we
not suck this time i said i was back
the quick rematch let's just win goal
starter you guys get in their heads
this all that matters
now we have oh it's a no problem war
it's a no problem
of the no problems
okay okay here we go
whoa
that was you
no wait let's not go to the blame zone
what do you mean
i thought it was a self goal i always
overestimate like how much that side
roll is gonna really help me out
i think
i expect it to like jet a little more
but if you do it from a standing
situation it's a love hate but mainly
i'm defending
nice got a little touch
yeah the pressure good pressure
coming all the way back
oh no
it's back
turkey
by then losing it
we're losing
yay
don't worry guys it was a heroic scene
oh it's okay it's
okay didn't expect that
okay oh
[ __ ]
yes yes
all right we are still open
all right
thank you that's going to come central
it's going to come central bouncing oh
tabaru overnight
no problem to the top corner
no problem
spam it oh that thing sat down so
beautifully
everyone was expecting the big bounce
hey i'm back i'm back
taste the blood
you taste it you want more they're
bleeding oh
not good not good
all right so so so
i'm learning soon how can we learn from
this everyone came to the corner right
in front of the goal if someone's hand
goal
you don't need to come right into the
goal with them all right and then we
like jocked each other up no one's fault
yeah
you're jocking me up you guys
this is a taste fish oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh no that's gonna go wide sorry
sorry tay that was not a taste fish
taste bash is just the oh [ __ ]
it's wide or it's tall
oh [ __ ]
yes nice clear
house
you got that kish
oh yeah
oh
almost high enough
rob stay back stay back oh yeah make a
play on it
see going right to that yeah i'm in the
corner i missed yeah oh man i would have
blown that
oh that was an ariel
they're getting cheeky
sorry
nice shot
no problem no problem it's a cinderella
story
nice shot a cinderella story oh
that little blooper in
all right i'm back
go for it
oh god
it's wide but i'm nervous
i'm going out afterwards oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah i hit you on purpose oh yeah
okay okay
yeah yeah
no problem come on man we're being no
problem people hey they were too that's
true they should be saying no problem
because they took that
and they put it in
if anything all right we should say nice
shots stay strong
what a shock that's where hugely i'm
saying that
don't tell me to stay back
sometimes that roll does the trick
you guys have all the makings
for something big
ah too fast like that
i can't handle my own speed
that's my problem
all right i'm leaving a little bit
oh i shouldn't have left a little bit
oh yes
mary i knocked it did you just pull ball
me right into that that was sweet
nicely i knew i couldn't get there it's
honestly if you can hit them it makes
you go faster than you can with boost so
i it's a dangerous maneuver
special but if you can that's the kiss
the other car
then do it
it's just kind of rude she pats you on
the back oh god here we go just gonna
put my oh damn it no that's a kiss fish
all right let's leave it up stitch
oh
he was there he was waiting can you
clear that nice nice tank money
strong d
oh they just sunk it into their end for
us
hello can you guys say that
blue and steady
bam
kiss making it
hit it with a halo all right here we go
whoa
it's a whole jumble ups
so that's when i don't like uh ball
cam because i can't see the ground yeah
because it's a real it's like
it spins you around a little bit oh hi
you came back here oh god that went way
too fast
nice i think it's time for a dance
oh my gosh
yeah
no problem victory
wow i said replay on that one i killed
it we just like uh
oh my god i'm amazing look at all them
goosers
all right guys
that
is uh
our hot look at the rocket league dlc
thank you for joining us for that one
game in which we totally won i always
win that's true we did but that was like
we had a good start
it's a dip a little bit of a dip just to
you know broccoli is so fun you guys
it's
some of the
some of the most fun i've had for a free
game i would gladly give them money
because i've put so many hours oh
because i got on playstation plus that's
right right yeah me too yeah that was
that was interesting right it was the
dlc super worth it that the paint colors
are you can do some really cool stuff
if you guys are playing rocket league
and you want to play us hit us up on
twitter we'll try to get some matches
going and uh yeah that's it thanks for
joining us for some rocket league
awesomeness
take it easy you take care
you